c'est le mois de ramadhan qui coïncide
avec notre mois de janvier et l'année
1384 de l'hégire c'est tout simplement
l'année 1965 de l'ère chrétienne
c'est le début du ramadan ce mois sacré
durant lequel les musulmans pratiquent
le jeûne est aujourd'hui bien connue en
france mais en 1965
cette tradition était décrite avec une
pointe d'exotisme gestes familiers que
l'on accomplit dans une cuisine moderne
de paris avec la même simplicité presque
rituelle que sous la tente en plein
désert ou au coin des rues en fête des
médinas du monde entier au cours des
années 1970 les sujets consacrés au
ramadan se multiplient à la télévision
et aborde notamment les difficultés que
peuvent rencontrer certains travailleurs
comme sur ce chantier en 1979
strictement rien entre lever et fin du
jour même pas un verre d'eau les autres
j'ai trouvé une place j'ai l'opposé et
pourquoi vous ne mangez pas parce que
c'est comme un carême que les
journalistes illustre ans habitant à la
table de femmes musulmanes
objectif faire découvrir aux
téléspectateurs les recettes
traditionnelles de rupture du jeûne
le repas du soir qui va aisni toute la
famille après le coucher du soleil
commence par la traditionnelle survint
une soupe à base de mouton et de blé
vers une grille et après la chorba de
nombreux reportages s'intéresse aux
fameuses pâtisseries orientales
une autre tradition du ramadan exemple
chez sony soit en 2006 à la bien ma
croûte qu'est la ive corne de gazelle ou
encore bat lanoye des pâtisseries à base
de beurre et de miel qui ont beaucoup de
succès même si parfois assez n'étant
plus obligés de mentir pour les parce
que chaque fois ils me prennent un
gâteau au la line hilali n'a alors je
leur dédie light ne craignez rien c'est
light
fin des années 2000 le ramadan est
désormais ancré dans la société
française la télévision s'intéresse
alors à son impact économique les
opérations spéciales ramadhan certifiée
halal font en effet grossir le chiffre
des grandes enseignes une bonne affaire
en effet pour les supermarchés pendant
le mois de ramadan certaines grandes
surfaces réalisent 7% de leur chiffre
d'affaires uniquement avec les produits
destinés aux musulmans en france 66 %
des musulmans pratiquent le ramadan
selon une étude de l'ifop paru en 2019
ces moments de joie tu me rendes plaisir
[Musique]